so can you explain to us what happened
with Dave Landau and Stephen Crowder so
as far as Dave Lando said he was on
Michael Mouse's show he um he used to be
the third chair on crowder and then he
basically had this contract dispute and
uh they just leave the door to the
bathroom open yeah
very small bladder he's a ass absolutely
chat gbt's uh about Ryan still didn't
close it famously small black anyway
what happened anyway so they so he was
third chair and then essentially they
had this like you know contract thing
and it was very heavy-handed like he was
saying he was trying to uh he wasn't
allowed to promote his dates his
comments his comedy dates right and
basically so he he used to be Anthony
cumia's um co-host and then he got
poached by Crowder but he's like I
didn't get a pay raise he's like I went
to go you're moving from New York to
Dallas he's like I didn't get a pay
raise I went to go do it and so part of
the deal is you get to promote your road
like shows and you'll make a lot of
money doing those shows and then they're
like you're not allowed to you still got
a club
and if you need to push the magnet in
yeah
you're good you're good yeah anyway what
happened anyway it's fine I didn't even
wipe because I had to get back smart
move
um but anyways he was like wasn't
allowed to promote his dates like you
know just if I'm right here and I'm
saying like hey catch me this this
Saturday in Morris Plains New Jersey
whatever but uh he was like you're not
allowed to do that and they were gonna
if he was five minutes late not for the
start time of the show but he had like a
time to be there to write they're like
he had a party clause in his car you get
sent home he's like he's gonna get sent
home and docked that day's pay
which is like it's just I don't know it
seems like a horrible environment malice
showed that part of the contract they
had all that in it yeah and then he
accepts the extra crazy because it's
like and then he wanted to own his
special because he because he uh uh
Crowder I guess they did Crowder getting
back in a stand-up or whatever so then
they did a show together but he Dave
headlined because he's like you know
very like uh well-seasoned comedian and
he shot this special and Crowder gave
him the door like the money from the
door and then after this whole thing
Crowder was gonna like release his
special because he's like I own it
because I gave you the door and he's
like you don't own my special
like no you don't just we were we were
talking with Landau about buying his
special yeah we talked to a couple
comedians about like buying and right
billboard yeah this is nuts because
Crowder I mean just like two months ago
he's on our show right here sitting
where you're sitting Ryan and he was
just complaining about the bad contract
deal it was still a it was just an offer
letter at the time it wasn't a full
contract but he was pissed he was pissed
that it was just a low ball offer he was
just he didn't even there was like they
weren't even negotiating he was just mad
at the crappy offer and then he turned
around and I haven't heard his side of
the story according to Dave and you said
they showed the contract another thing
they land outside which was crazy is he
said that uh Crowder brought him in his
office and told him to his face that he
goes you made more money than I did last
year land out did to there's no way that
that's possible really yeah because
you're just saying he's the salary was
he didn't take the salary no no no no uh
that it it is actually decently common
that a business owner will make less
money than an employee that's the actual
salary I like his net worth grew by
higher which when you're talking about
yeah
trick him but it sounded like this was
like an Earnest being like you know
you're actually you know just as an
adult but you're like nobody thinks that
like you're saying that he told land
Orlando's salary was higher than his
yeah he goes you made more money than me
last year and Linda's like there's no
way that I made more money than you last
year yeah that's how much how much did
he make and how much did credit is a
question I mean I don't know I don't
think
no but I don't think Crowder makes as
much money as people think he makes how
much did he turn down from David wire
what was daily wire 50 million and then
he asked okay so he makes more money 120
million so yeah yeah hold on hold on but
that's full of production full
production the entire company 30
employees or whatever so it was like I
don't know but here's the thing like
even regardless I don't know the ins and
outs of that world really like exactly
what's going on there and but more
importantly the if he wants to give him
less money it's like the perfect deal
because you're like hey let's say I'm
only giving you like not that high of a
salary to come work at his show or
whatever right but then he goes yes but
we'll promote all your dates that takes
him three seconds an episode and you
basically make all your money on the
road so it's almost like you're getting
subsidized so it's like I'm paying you
less but it's like I'm paying you an
exposure in a way that's real because
you actually do get to go cash that out
by like going on the road making money
so it's like it's such like a win-win
for people that like I just don't
understand why you would have ever I
don't get that part well so here's the
question for those that watch Crowder
does land did Lando not ever shout out
any of his dates he did he said he was
doing it and then eventually they were
like you're not you're you're uh the new
yeah like you will shout out your dates
you're allowed to do it behind the
paywall shout out your dates on the
Friday show I guess and then uh and then
they're like we'll do it one time a week
on a medium of our choosing so that
could be like a tweet we we had
Luke on the show he has his own
membership website his own t-shirt
business and I literally don't care that
he shouts it out yeah it's the same deal
yeah I mean this is a constant Shout Out
24 7. every time you're on website or
whatever yeah but again like every
podcast you go for the guests you go
what are your plugs like you know it's
pretty normal but but I'm saying like
for the guests I get for we're talking
about someone who's paid to be at the
company when and people are like oh yeah
but you know uh Luke doesn't work for
you or whatever and I'm like he's on the
show for like six months or whatever
every single night Monday through Friday
you're right I don't pay them it's like
shout out your thing but everybody here
shouts out whatever they want and that
kind of makes sense yeah yeah
April 29th for the take Human Action
tour take human actiontour.com and then
and then I guess the problem is Ian
You're Gonna Be Tardy that day and so
I'm gonna have to send you I might be
theater
that's the other thing too because we've
got other people who come on the show
show that like Ian was just like I'm not
going to be here that day I'm like oh
whatever yeah you know like it's weird
to be a contract being like if you're
not here on time you're tardy and you
got to go home yeah that's personal that
was another thing too is so I guess they
were like you have to be here on Fridays
they're like you have to be here on
Fridays which then doesn't really allow
him to do weekend dates because usually
like you're performing Friday night and
then he's like Crowder was like no
showing all the time on Fridays anyways
so he's just obviously disgruntled and
he just felt like he was being treated
poorly it seemed like they wanted to
just get him out of there which I don't
understand why they would go through all
of this when they could have just been
like we're not renewing your contract
yes they can't did they cancel his old
contract and then offered them he said
he said they offered a 1099 him oh yeah
make him an employee making uh no that
was a contract contract that's like a
contract you don't even work here you're
just a contractor of ours it's
devastating I love both those guys so
much I mean I don't know them either
very well either of them did that well
but I would really enjoyed spending time
with both of them New York comedy yeah
Dave's hilarious what an amazing yeah so
uh
quarter black Garrett's got the tweets
official landout Dave and myself are
launching a new sketch talk show on The
Blaze called normal World released
release date TBD yeah kind of crazy that
was another thing I think he said that
Crowder wanted to like own that or
something normal world was just like a
sketch he made like he threatened to if
he released it like because he was gonna
fire three or four people it's almost
like an abuse a kid that was physically
abused now abusing their own children
like Stephen has been through hell such
that now he's turning around what that's
what landed he goes it was like a guy
who used to be bullied that's what
Landau said he was like a guy used to be
bullied and now is the bully that's like
I'm paraphrasing well that's I mean this
like changes a lot some people are
asking me have I changed my view on the
whole daily wire thing because of this
and my response is I've not heard what
Stephen has to say about this and I I
like Crowder I we talked to him to a
great deal about business this sounds
abnormal and so
you know look I like Dave too so I don't
know but I will say my first bias is
whenever there's like a former employee
coming out and saying bad things about
the company they worked for I'm like I'm
kind of not surprised that someone who's
knowing her with a company saying bad
things about sure there's two sides to
every story and I'm sure all the people
were currently working with Crowder are
like I don't think that's not true but
uh then again you saw the first time
that like a on-air personality is like a
ego guy I mean this is like standard in
this industry it's like whatever and
there's a part of that that comes with
the thing or whatever but but also like
it's it's you you don't know I mean look
at Veritas right if you get all these
people this letter comes out claiming
that James is a bad person or whatever
but it turns out some of these employees
never witnessed anything and a bunch of
employees actually quit and go work with
James instead so clearly something was
not true about what they were claiming
yeah you never know man it kind of feels
like Landau was Dave I know you're
listening going in late a lot not to the
performances like you said well no so he
said that he was like his
admitted he goes I was coming in late
but not for the show he's not late for
his call I guess like you know yeah but
shows for that reason they were probably
having business meetings and like Landau
again man we're waiting on him again
again yeah and if you're doing
production for a show and there's like
hey guys we got a new notice from you
know the person who was gonna bring in
the music is Dave here Dave's so when's
it going to get and then he showed up
five minutes before air time and they're
like did you get the briefing on the new
thing we're doing in the morning he's
like no it's fine to me all that stuff's
like yeah it could be standard he said
she said but they're not mentioning the
dates to me is the only thing where
you're just like I just don't see any
Rhyme or Reason Why that could possibly
make sense unless unless you just kind
of like are so detached from the
stand-up world now where you're just
like I don't really like it just seems
heavy-handed it seems like why is that
the other stuff yeah that's all exactly
what you're saying could be true or
The Blaze colluded with Landau and
quarter black Garrett offering him fat
cash to besmirch the good name of
crowder that's right that's what we
should do with BuzzFeed to get the price
down so then we can swoop in and buy it
let's be smirch BuzzFeed you don't I
will I will freely this merge BuzzFeed
anytime the first 20 minutes of the show
we did that but that's why I would never
want to buy BuzzFeed you're right it's
like buying a polished turd it's just
you know I'm excited for this polish
turd factory I'm really excited for uh
he released it on YouTube
once a week or something I think he just
did I think this was like a pilot yeah
yeah exactly how's Steven doing on
Rumble Evan
I think I was I was actually watching
the premiere of malice and then people
in the comments were like uh Rumble was
crashing
while they're so they were like because
people are like I'm trying to watch both
and Rumble that they're unable like I
guess I don't know rumble's growing too
quickly yeah like you must had a bag
come at you from Rumble no matter what
offered a bag of money uh we've had
offers from a bunch of companies I've
talked like and they're just all bad my
view of let me first say this
I I I like all of these companies for
the work they do because it's very
important stuff
um we use Rumble for the website we use
Rumble for our video player but every
deal that I've received feels like
it feels like you know a business guy
comes to me and they're thinking to
themselves how stupid is Tim Poole let
me try and figure it out and then
they're like oh crap he's actually good
at business and they leave yeah so like
the deals that we've been offered have
been like I look at I'm like did you
really not think that I knew like do you
think I don't know how to deal with
contracts in business and they were like
it's just standard stuff and I'll be
like okay dude but here's the thing put
the weird stuff those contracts work on
people yeah so whenever I see people
doing these deals I'm just like
it's like could you imagine I like
you're a regular person trying to play
in the NBA you're saying there could
easily be like in six months you're like
hey all those people are getting sued to
give that money back I'm telling you
right now I think without naming any one
of these companies specifically when
Crowder came out was like how dare the
daily wire do this to me my attitude
with that is kind of like every single
company every single one is ripping off
the people they've signed I mean the
payment industry this is a tale as old
as time and just the entertainment
industry it's it's just like to to to to
varying degrees that someone is being
taken advantage of and uh and and I it's
like yeah but I think that a lot of
times it's like if you think of it like
a record label it's like you're
basically like a venture company where
you're like Hey we're doing gonna put
money into 10 things we're gonna lose
money on you know most of them and then
one will make 10 money and I guess
you're ripping that guy off but the
other ones you lost money on let me I'll
explain to you guys how it works right
let's let's do hypothetical
some dude's got a hundred thousand
subscribers on YouTube and they're like
I I want to make something bigger than
this I want to I want to increase my
money I need help I don't know what to
do
in today's day and age it's very very
easy to ramp up your own company when
you're at a level like 50 to 100 000 or
like more than 50 000 subscribers so
what's happening is these companies are
looking at people who are hitting that
Mark and they're thinking before this
person figures out how easy it is to
make themselves Rich we better lock them
into a heavy contract yeah and that's
basically what it is it's not easy for
everyone to do that though you know
there's lots of people that aren't that
type of person yes but it's like
anyone could do it and it's not
difficult it's just like could such like
a arbitrary word though it's like you
know like you know anyone could probably
run a marathon but it's like you know
it's unlikely that you know most people
are going to run the Iron Man you know
what I mean so to say that oh they would
have otherwise a lot of people wouldn't
do wouldn't otherwise so if somebody
were to create their so uh
you want to create your own website your
own Subscription Service it'll be done
in three days you retain all of the
money instead what they're doing is
they're going well I don't know how this
works so I'll just sign a contract that
sounds good and what the contract really
does is it gives the person you sign to
like 90 of your Revenue oh you're saying
more big established people in Canada
this company in Canada that was uh they
did something like that and then they
stopped paying all their creators
recently who I don't know what their
name is I saw Ethan uh Ethan Klein Klein
was tweeting about it uh oh it was like
a multi-final network something those
ncns seem like such as here's what
happens
a guy with 100 000 followers has a has a
potential monthly income rate of maybe
like a hundred thousand dollars per
month out of the hundred thousand
subscribers he needs to convert 10 into
paying monthly users that's a really
high conversion ten percent I bet you
most people's conversion is not 10 it
was called BB TV by the way okay sure
let's say let's say uh 20 percent
no no I think it's like what percentage
I'm sorry two percent more or less
will not allow you to buy BuzzFeed with
let's let's put it this way
100 million you like that let's say
someone's got okay a subscribers
probably not the right way to put it um
100 000 viewers yeah consistent of
viewers viewers who are like you could
you could have a bunch of subscribers
and then like you're all your core
audience yeah so if you can convert 10
000 people let's just put it this way 5
000 people of your following of a
hundred thousand at ten bucks a month
and you're making half a million dollars
a year what's happening these companies
are coming in and say we'll pay you a
hundred thousand dollars a year to come
and work for us and these people not
having actually just spent the 10
minutes to make a website are like that
sounds great they like they get locked
into understand where you're coming from
okay but there's let's say you're
someone else that you're streaming on
YouTube right like a huge portion of
your streaming your huge portion of the
YouTube money just from comes from like
doing the streams then cutting up all
the clips after so they're like hey why
don't I take this like guaranteed money
to go do the streams I'm gonna put the
videos on YouTube after it's like I know
like to some people it's like yeah sure
that's like a no-brainer it's not really
costing me anything I I think it's I I
think it's exploitative some people are
like not business people they're like
I'm just a Creator I I'm not that's what
it comes down that's what happens those
are the people they prey on I would
agree with that if it was 20 years ago
yeah when it was difficult to move
around in certain industries but now
we're in the era where you can get you
you can literally just Google search
WordPress plugin WordPress API and if
you don't want to do that you can just
like Google search website company and
then you you type in your credit card
and then a week later like your
website's done here's how you log in and
then it's like you officially just
instantly have your own patreon you have
your own subscribers I think you're
there's two things there's like being an
artist being a Creator and there's being
an entrepreneur and you're sort of like
fusing them together like it's obvious
that ones and they're the two you're
hand in hand it would be nice
you just get on the microphone and we're
talking about people who've already
started their own channels already built
their own following so they already have
a bit of a favor already done everything
they need to do to me to monetize Their
audience I remember watching a story in
BuzzFeed about a woman with 300 000
subscribers who was working as a
waitress and a little girl started
screaming like oh my God you're so and
so why are you working as a waitress I
said she ran back into the back room and
started crying it's like I get it they
don't know the only thing they're
missing is one sentence being told to
them that one sentence Bridges the gap
between how they're not making money and
and and Their audience and all they need
is for someone to be like oh uh dial
this Plug-In or I'll tell you what hire
this company you're done sure
but here's what what's happening is
we've I've talked to to various creators
about would they want to work with us
would they want to do a deal with us can
we sign them and the answer is always no
because people are like I've already got
my own platform I don't I don't need to
do a deal with anymore I totally get it
yeah right on have a nice day and then
I've actually when I approach people
from an honest point and I say like
here's what your numbers are here's what
we can expect here's where we want to be
they say then why would I sign with you
and I'm like why would you
why why why why would you yeah I have a
promotion and then promotion yeah and
it's and and promotion is similar to
what Dave why Day land I was on and why
Crowders on Rumble they're pushing him
oh God every time he goes yeah it
depends on the type of content you're
making some things require like a lot of
you know of your head's Ram I think that
uh
20 years ago you're a musician and
you're like I don't know how to sell
albums today you already have Twitter
you already have YouTube you already
have a Facebook you already have
connection your audience I'll explain it
this way every single company that's
reached out to us saying have you
considered publishing a book have you
considered creating this product or this
product it's all a scam here's what they
do
they they they they've come to me and
said we want to do a book with you Tim
and I say tell me what that means look
we're gonna we're gonna work with you
you write out your ideas for the book
you write out chapter treatments we then
work with you on Crafting each of those
chapters then we're going to get your
book we're going to sell it it's going
to hit number one and I say and and how
is that gonna how are you going to do
that it's perfect all you got to do is
go on your show and tell people to buy
your book yeah and I'm like the promoter
like yeah can you tweet about this more
that's what all of it is so these people
think they're like if I sign with them I
get a look man but as you the network
you actually do have a mechanism you do
know how to like you know build
something so you have that expertise but
we're not something we're not talking
about a person with no followers and no
following that we're trying to craft
we're talking about a prominent
personality being told sign with us and
give us 90 of your existing revenue and
we'll give you back 10 yeah here's the
reason it didn't work on me I run a
company so when all these companies came
to me and said here's how here's our tip
our standard structure I said
i i as a literal quote I said are you
asking me for a loan
yeah I'm not going to say who I was
talking to but these companies come to
me and they're like we're going to
guarantee you this much money we're
gonna do this for you're gonna do that
for you it's they basically want to give
you a job working for yourself
they want me to give them they want us
to sign over money right sign over all
of the of the money we already make and
our future prospects our growth
projections and everything in exchange
for less money than we make now yeah but
if you're somebody who's not bridged
that Gap by simply setting up your own
subscription website like locals patreon
or a website you don't know your own
worth so they're trying to get you to
sign before you can realize you're worth
10 times what they're offering you
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time